my name's Belize nation today the more
you give the more you receive over to
you Robert Kiyosaki I don't know what
the heck both people think about money
but that's what I get a lot of as kind
of this well you know money's not
spiritual I'm just saying it's your
attitudes you know a person's attitude
towards money I make a lot of money but
I give a lot you know what I mean
it goes to biblical principle the more
you give the more you receive
so when I meet somebody who's not
doesn't have any money it just means
that they're not giving something yeah
you know so a lot of times there's
people who would like more but they're
not giving anything so they're like my
poor debt you know he belonged to the
labor unions and he wanted to work less
and get paid more
well that's anti-religious to me yeah if
you want to get paid more work more give
more that's how I see it what do you
think well your opinions count you're
not on that you know
as much so people want to hear from you
now it's two more who gives more and I
really shake what do you think I think
equally
we'll play it safe and see police
give more friends and you will receive
more but it's true
in general I like to give you like to
give I think it's it's it just makes you
feel good like it's not giving trying to
get something back it's just whether
it's an employee or a relationship or a
partner or media or whoever customer it
feels good to give and a help and when
you do that people want to help you back
out and so I would try to do it without
an exterior motive I'm trying to get XYZ
so I'm gonna give give to give and
you'll be surprised at how much comes
back so question the day I'd love to
know a story of when you gave without an
ulterior motive and you had a result in
your life or your business leave in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning just bite me think we
need that in slow motion